priorité à l'éducation à l'europe ou à
la lutte contre les inégalités jacques
attali a une vision précise du monde et
de la france une vision qu'il a exposée
durant plus d'une heure devant un
amphithéâtre plein l'économiste et
écrivain consulté par tous les
présidents de la république est revenu
notamment sur la prochaine campagne
présidentielle avec ironie l'europe à
l'europe la laïcité comment la formation
des chômeurs je n'ai pas cité sac est
pour moi absolument majeur la formation
des chômeurs ses tacles et dont on ne
parle pas de leur sujet et donc
forcément le prochain président de comme
les trois précédents sous chirac ont été
élus avec un mandat explicite ne rien
faire et ils ont parfaitement d'objecter
leurs ventes
le fondateur de l'organisation
humanitaire action contre la faim a
surtout exposé sa vision pour le long
terme lui qui estime que la france peut
être la grande puissance du 21e siècle
un propos convaincants pour ses
auditeurs d'un soir je pense que c'était
un débat oui très très constructif et et
qui nous aiderait je pense que les
étudiants h essais à aborder l'avenir
avec certaines ce qui m'a marqué c'est
de me dire qu'aujourd'hui une entreprise
comme burke on voit qu'avec un peu un
poussin et on arrive ce que ça va
devenir un un truc énorme dit qu'en fait
ça va tout va tellement vite que c'est
déjà en train de en train de disparaître
jacques attali risque d'être une
nouvelle fois convoité à la proche des
présidentielles lui qui ne se reconnaît
pour le moment dans aucun candidat